yeah my tongue is talking to my brain
right now saying what are you doing to
me
you know
feeling the tears
[Music]
hey what's going on buddy for first week
Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Austin Butler he's
a golden Global award-winning actor and
up for an Oscar in this year's best
actor category for his performance is
Elvis in the acclaimed baslerman
directed by opic you can also catch him
in the war drama miniseries masters of
the air coming soon to Apple Plus as
well as the highly anticipated Dune
sequel due out later this year Austin
Butler welcome to the show I'm so happy
to be here with you well that's lovely
to hear how are you around spicy food
and what's going through your head as
you prepare to take on The Gauntlet well
I mean as we were just talking about I
uh I'm I'm like a Cholula sort of
sriracha Guy usually
but as you said after today you know all
bets are off who knows
[Music]
thank you
foreign
maple
[Music]
hmm
that's lovely
this is how all the interviews start
though I always see them oh that's
really lovely that's not bad
it's just a very mild Spike
[Music]
so for more casual observers of Elvis I
think it's surprising to learn how
robust his film career actually was with
more than 30 titles to his name as an
actor what do you see in Elvis's
filmography
um
well it's interesting because the films
that he did before he went to the Army I
mean especially the last one king creone
was directed by Michael Curtis who
directed Casablanca when you see Elvis's
performance in that I think it shows so
much promise
and then he got back from two years away
he wanted to come back and be a serious
actor and not sing in all his films but
then they didn't make money
and so
people around him the colonel and and
other people say you know audiences
don't want to see a movie where you
don't sing and if you want to have a
career you gotta you gotta do this and
um and it breaks my heart because it
wasn't really I think what he wanted to
do but then he ends up getting caught in
that
that Whirlwind and and sort of the
promise that one day I'll get to that
point you know
so it makes me sad that Elvis never got
that chance to really train to the point
that he could excel in the way that I
know that he wanted to
there's this book called being Elvis
alone in life where they tell the story
about
um and that was his deep regret was that
he never made a classic film and he
really he really believed at that point
that he would be forgotten after he died
which is just just so sad and
mind-blowing to me insane because he
felt like music would come and go but
that a film would last forever in some
way
um and I wish he was here today to see
all the people around the world who just
adore him so much
[Music]
shaquanda's Banshee rash all right
this Ranch is always a nice thing to dip
a hot wing right right and then here
they are just uh combining sort yeah
there we go
there we go there we go yeah you start
me slow
make me feel confident and then
and then Sucker Punch me at the end I'm
sure
and then I read that Tom Hanks gifted to
do a chrome typewriter and the two of
you began an immediate pen pal
relationship in character is Elvis in
the kernel how did that serve as an
effective character development exercise
for you
it was a way that I never even thought
of rehearsing before
um I'd heard the sort of apocryphal
thing that Tom gives typewriters away
and when he when he got to Australia
this chrome typewriter shows up at my
door and we were staying in the same
apartment complex and he was he was a
couple floors uh above me and and it was
and he he wrote one letter from Tom
Hanks and then another from Carlton
Parker and uh and so in that one you
you'd say you know my boy would I I
watched your new film and this is what I
think of this and
when you're typing it and especially on
a typewriter where you can't edit as
much you really have to think about is
this what that person believes and so
then I would end up saying you know I
just got back from Hawaii and Priscilla
and I did this and suddenly now it was
expanding
the memories that I was now having as
Elvis
and uh and then allowed me to to put it
down on paper in that way and
um it was a really cool way of
rehearsing
[Music]
that's really nice how far did you get
in that Wing you know I kind of oh you
devoured them I know you know it was
kind of an accident you know sometimes
it falls off the phone yeah I'm not
trying to push the pace or anything
Austin no
I saw Brolin was throwing them away and
something keeping his place oh yeah you
know what there's a garbage can over
there there's a little I don't need
we'll leave them here yeah yeah little
hoop action graveyard yeah in front of
us
so it's impressive to learn that your
acting coach Larry Moss has worked with
everyone from you to Helen Hunt Leonardo
Dicaprio and Jim Carrey when you're
watching films can you tell how an actor
is trained or is the whole point that
you can't really see any technique
these are such good questions
um I um
one thing that I love is when it feels
like close-up Magic
like Sam Rockwell is a good example he's
so amazing with physical life it's
because he came from Eisner training
for me what I also find is that with
most actors and most of the great actors
that I've worked with they're pulling
from so many things so it's not like
there's just one technique or something
it's you kind of just fine right it's
not like oh I'm an Adler person or I'm a
Meisner person or I'm a stanislavski
person or whatever exactly what about
UDA Hagen the UDA Hagen method ever do
anything for you you know that's not a
name that gets name checked as much as
Meisner and stainless I love that you
mentioned that yeah lougan was was
um
certain acting teachers it's almost like
they're talking down to their students
but UDA was never she never seemed to be
that way she was she was like a working
actor who had been trying things for a
long time trying to figure things out
pulled from many different
um
Styles and teaching techniques and that
sort of thing and brought together
different exercises and she's amazing I
love that you bring her most people
don't that's that's really thank you
well you know what I have plenty of time
to knock this thing off the tracks are
you ready yeah
are you ready to move on here to Sauce
number four
the Los Calientes
[Music]
that's tasty
so to kind of piggyback on the
conversation we were just having I know
that your acting Journey began with you
and your mom taking the long trips from
Orange County to Los Angeles that you
can take acting classes thinking back on
that time is there an acting exercise
that you found to be most useful maybe
something that you learned back then and
still used to this day and then can you
give us another one that stands out in
your mind for just being ridiculous
yeah
um as far as what was very useful was
um I did this class it was a class where
you
sit sort of sort of miznering Base where
come to class they give you a scene
that's a couple pages long
you read it once and then you put it
under your chair and then you get up in
front of the class and you have a
partner who has the same scene then you
sit down and they've got two cameras on
you so there's a there's a close-up on
each each of you the cameras on a
close-up so it can tell when you're
lying and the teachers there watching
the Monitor and you'd say what are they
feeling the other person
happy sad fear anger love and then and
then you go okay love
um so how do you respond to that because
sometimes they'd be angry and and there
would be a line that you wouldn't expect
to be an angry lion but that person had
something go on in that day that you
know they got cut off in traffic or
something they brought that into class
and so you got to respond to that and
not just come up with the idea that
you're having
um so that taught me a lot about how
there's so many different ways that a
scene can be played there's really
unexpected things that can happen and
really listen
um but the ridiculous things I mean I
were like pretend you're a chicken and
you're like clucking around the room and
and that sort of thing you know a lot of
a lot of them is ridiculous I heard a
great story about uh Brando it was in an
acting class and they I hope that this
story is true that that they said to the
whole class pretend you're chickens and
there's a nuclear bomb that's about to
hit and all all the other chickens in
the class
and they're running around freaking out
and Brandon was just sitting there just
pecking at the ground and the teacher
goes what are you doing what are you
what are you doing I said that there's a
bomb about Dan he goes I'm a chicken I
don't know what a bomb is
so yeah I like that one
well speaking of nuclear chicken are you
ready to move on here to the halfway
point
I always liked the compilation of just
people's reaction to everyone okay all
right yeah I'm feeling that a little bit
what does it say pizza chocolate
Curry yeah it's kind of guys does that
mean that these are the notes in it or
is this Bloody Mary is does that mean
you can put this in a Bloody Mary yeah
that means let it rip on a bloody mary
but it's like got a kind of a spicy
curry Vibe this one I feel like yeah
that's I actually really like that there
we go there we go nice mom
is it true that Quentin Tarantino will
oftentimes request another take even if
he has everything that he needs just
because making movies kicks ass yeah
there's two things I can say I I I don't
want to speak out of school but
um
one thing
it's really awesome when you're on set
the first time that I heard this it was
uh it was just so cool because I mean
I've talked a lot about how much Clinton
meant to me and it was just always my
dream to work with him and but he uh
we're on set and he
he says okay we got it we're gonna do
one more you know why and the entire
crew screams because we love making
movies
and the first time you're there you kind
of go oh you you're not in on it and so
Brad and Leo everybody's like because we
love making movies which is there are
sets that are so sterile there are sets
where there's no joy there are sets
where people are like just at a job
um and you're trying to like create
something that you're gonna give to the
world you know and and um with Quinn
that was so cool because it just changes
the atoms in the room and then the next
time that we love making movies happens
now you're in on it yeah and then so
every new crew member or actor whoever
then suddenly they're a part of the
tribe at that point saying we love
making movies
torch bear Mushroom Man
oh yeah
imagine straight mushroom straight
shroom off the top yeah
we're gonna start um
hallucinating stuff
God willing hopefully
here we go man
so I've heard you describe working on
the Iceman Cometh on Broadway as a true
artistic breakthrough moment for you
can you break down this quote of yours
you are the editor when you're on stage
I mean we were doing the Iceman Cometh
which is which is quite a dark play
Some Nights the audience treated it like
it was a comedy the next night they were
treated like it was a uh like they would
you could hear a pin drop in the room
um and they sort of take on this
Collective mind and and so I had an
older actor tell me like stand behind
the curtain and feel the energy of the
audience before you walk out and so I
would do that every night I had this
little ritual that I would do but I
wanted the last things I would do before
I went up to the dressing room was sort
of just you hear the chatter of the
audience and you feel they're all sort
of like unifying in that moment
um but then you're on stage and the
times that I felt it
it was such a amazing feeling
to feel the audience in the palm of your
hand where they're hanging on every word
that you're saying
and you know that you could pause and
sometimes I would hold the pause even a
little longer
and then when you finally speak it's it
it has a little bit more power
um I saw Denzel do it you know I mean
that was one of the greatest things I've
ever seen was
some of the most brilliant acting I had
ever laid eyes on he knew it the
audience knew it the other actors know
it and you'd expect when somebody's done
something brilliant that they would go
okay I'm gonna do that again tomorrow
and he wouldn't sometimes he'd never do
it again but it was just new life every
night it was that that complete presence
so it's that thing like there's no one
perfect way to do a scene you know
um but yeah that's the editing thing
thank you
all right so these last four this is
where it kicks up a notch I hear
Cheers Cheers
here we go
we should do this all the time this is
great man this is you're welcome back
anytime
um I have a gun oh
now this one I think starts off kind of
nice but then it has that like
tail on it that starts to kick in yeah
yeah right a little time sort of like
this time release fire that's where
you're over my tongue right now yeah and
you know you bite into it you think
you're good you're like that's not so
bad up front yeah a little Calypso off
the off the tip yeah
yeah Clips off the tip and then just
spice off the rip you know spice up the
spice off yeah that's their new tagline
yeah
super hot Caribbean style
yeah I feel that yeah there we go yeah
now it starts to run and yeah we're in
it we're in it yeah I feel it I feel
like swirling around in my mouth now
so unlike Elvis you didn't buy
happenstance have three years for the
physical transformation that you're
taking on in the upcoming Dune project
in your months of Navy SEAL like
training did you walk away with that
with a more creative or exciting way to
do cardio
yeah basically
work me until I would throw up every
time Duffy's he also I found him because
he's he's this sort of legend that he
was a Navy SEAL and then he started like
he betrayed Brad Pitt for Troy and uh
and he's just he's a legend and he's
just the nicest guy as well but he also
doesn't really like count reps he just
goes go for it and you're just going and
you're like how many of these am I going
to do and once you get to the point
where you're dying and you can hardly do
another he goes all right do 10 more and
that sort of thing and so and and
because he's so tough you you don't want
to let him die
and so so it's it's having a guy like
that around just going keep going keep
going and you're just pushing your body
to the absolute limit of what it can do
he says don't even look in the mirror
don't look at the scale like look at how
strong you are and that was really cool
all right well speaking of speaking of
strong how strong we are yeah
this next one is the bomb Beyond
Insanity oh yeah
it is a sauce the reputation that
perceives I've heard about this one
yeah so this is a real choose this is a
real cheers this is oh that's not the
last app the last step is the last step
all right that's what they say that's
what they said
yeah immediately
my tongue is talking to my brain right
now saying what are you doing to me
feeling the tears yeah
what are the qualities that you look for
in a restaurant when you're thinking
about becoming a regular you know I've
heard you talk about how restaurants
become like second homes to you when
you're in filming locations all over the
world
foreign
this is where it happens exactly
um all right
being a regular uh whatever
all right
um I uh
I look for a kind staff
I look for delicious coffee
I look for
um grapefruit
um something in a close proximity to
where I live
so they get hotter than this that's
crazy
peanut butter banana and bacon
sandwiches is overrated or underrated
I'm going for the oat milk let's see
what this is like I'll join you at the
party
it gives like a temporary relief and
then just oh you want oat milk as well
are you yeah I'm going right with you I
like that you're really you're coming
down
um uh what was the question
peanut butter banana and bacon
sandwiches overrated or underrated
[Music]
um
I mean it depends who you ask I think
that
I think they're underrated because
they're like thought of as some joke or
something like that to certain people
but they're really delicious
big fan of any peanut butter sandwich in
general like peanut butter and jelly is
one of my favorite things in the world
it's funny how certain people especially
in other countries don't think that
you're crazy for liking it they go I
don't understand like I had a French
person the other day I do not understand
this peanut butter and jelly yeah
it's like the comfort food for me you
know
this next one is Taco Vibes only we were
going right into the next one if you're
ready if you're ready Austin
this is where you start breaking down
the defenses right through the armor
it's an answer this is Taco Vibes only
Taco Vibes are just extreme burn danger
today
[Music]
yeah I'm okay
so you grew up in Anaheim California
almost midway between Disneyland and
Knott's Berry Farm which sounds like a
childhood's dream fulfilled
pound for pound what's the goat
amusement park attraction for you oh wow
great question um
it's a roller coaster at Knott's Berry
Farm so you start out faster it's called
like extreme or something you shoot and
you go up and over and down and then you
do loops and different things
I I rode that with my mom when when I
when it first opened and uh and we got
to the end of the ride and our hair is
just like you know you just went through
the whole wind tunnel and uh and and we
looked at each other and she goes I want
to do it again I was like yeah and so we
went and that point I mean you go to the
end of the line we didn't have fast
passes or anything and you make your way
through the line again we wrote it again
I think we did it like three or four
times in a row so we really liked that
one
yeah all right Austin all right
here we go my man
[Music]
well I'm not gonna
all right is that enough that's enough
of a dab right there
all right Cheers Cheers what a ride what
a ride this has been really fun
yeah going in I'm going on
and with that fight Austin Butler we
have climbed to the top of Scoville
Mountain the top of spice Mountain we've
reached it and I know it's been a trying
and challenging Journey which is why we
want to return it to a happy place you
know I know matter I know no matter how
crazy your life gets there's always
something there for you always something
you can count on and that is the iconic
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
so what we have here is a full Nissan
Plus no way okay are you serious you
playing this at a time and I'm just
curious how you make your peanut butter
and jelly sandwich you know we have some
different options here I'm curious about
your build the order of elements I'll
I'll talk you through your ratio yeah
take this one away off yeah is this is
so I make one for you at the same time
you know you know we're marrying each
other the whole time so I'm gonna I'll
do the same okay here we go this is this
is great I'm not I'm not gonna
I'm gonna wait for just one second so I
don't drip on yourself
all right
um so I'll talk you through some things
I'm a smooth peanut butter guy there we
go so that's what I'm gonna start with
some people only appear about one side
of the bread but then the jam soaks into
the bread certain people like that I
prefer when it's contained so you sort
of like you bring the peanut butter on
both sides and it kind of locks in the
jam
I I was the only kid in the elementary
school who got this letter that allowed
me to every every lunch walk home and
eat lunch with my mom and she'd have a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich waiting
for me and we'd watch some design show
like there was this one called Surprise
by Design where you would um make uh
like brick Pathways in their backyard
different things and then and then we
would go let's go do that and so we
bought bricks and try to make brick pads
on the backyard
um and uh so that was I have very fond
memories of great Jam because of that
um
[Music]
all right
so
don't be bashful with the uh
peanut butter
and I'm gonna have peanut butter and
jelly aficionados out there
coming at you yeah coming for you yeah
but you know what I'll take it this is
my technique
math is still just burning it's uh it's
amazing all right I haven't done this
with a the this really this is
animalistic um all right we're gonna
this is gonna make us up I'm gonna try
oh look at that I've never done that do
you like it
it's kind of fun actually
yeah it's like this is gonna be my new
therapy it's like
you know after a long day just
spreading grape jelly like this it's
really wild it like sends it in a sheet
it's amazing how they designed that
I feel like Bob Ross
well it does look like an artist at work
over here I gotta say
um
yeah just a sniffling Bob Ross
making a sandwich for my front Sean
[Music]
this is getting ridiculous guys
all right and we did the white bread
like I've been on a more of a wheat
bread thing but this is this is old
school right now all right and under
these circumstances thank you so much
together I feel so safe with you and you
gave me a sandwich a delicious peanut
butter and jelly sandwich we'll see and
it's really nice to actually wash down
with smoke milk
how is that is that okay under these
circumstances yeah it's one of the best
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches I've
ever had in my life oh it's good no the
way that kind of just kills that hot
sauce Gauntlet that's perfect so perfect
so perfect and look at you Austin Butler
taking on the wings of death making us a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich to call
credits and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
people know what you have going on in
your life
what do I have going on in my life right
now I'm
my mouth is completely numb and um I
I've made a new friend that I hope stays
in my life for a long time eating
wonderful peanut butter and jelly
um and um yeah it's been a whirlwind
lately so I look forward to
yeah you know many more fun times ahead
and and then a vacation yeah
we survived it
I'm actually gonna dig in on this a
little bit yeah me too actually
you know that's like
that's childhood right there
and it's Sneaky like really good against
the spice it's actually like like people
gotta do this when they come on just ask
yeah it has to be part of the recovery
yeah you just have a peanut butter and
jelly waiting for people in The Green
Room afterwards
great the peanut butter really cuts
through it
this conversation was so wonderful so
thank you man
hot ones fans exciting news the season
20 hot ones 10 pack is now available if
you've ever watched from home and
wondered to yourself how hot are the
wings really or been one of those people
that's like oh they're only taking one
bite well you know what if you think you
could do better now is the time to put
your money where your mouth is literally
with the hot ones season 20 10 pack
available exclusively at heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 20 hot ones 10 pack
get them while they're high
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]